nos dicen que la siguiente tabla muestra
las cantidades de material que anna
reciclo de modo que aquí tenemos los
diferentes materiales y de este lado las
diferentes cantidades cuantos kilogramos
de papel y aluminio reciclo anna pausa
en el vídeo y tratan de resolver esto
muy bien estamos pensando en papel y
aluminio el papel está justo aquí ella
reciclo doscientos setenta y siete
kilogramos de papel y el aluminio está
justo acá ella reciclo 134 kilogramos de
aluminio queremos la combinación o la
suma de papel y aluminio así que esto
será doscientos setenta y siete
kilogramos más 134 kilogramos en
realidad necesitamos averiguar cuánto es
277 + 134 y en muchos vídeos hemos
hablado sobre las diferentes maneras de
resolver esto podríamos decir bueno
vamos a descomponer el 134 y podríamos
comenzar por resolverlo en una recta
numérica a veces es divertido hacer esto
entonces si decimos que esta es nuestra
recta numérica y vamos a comenzar en 277
justo aquí primero podríamos agregar 100
porque aquí tenemos 100 así que hagamos
eso si sumamos 100 a donde llegamos pues
si sumamos 100 llegamos a 377 entonces
300 y escribiré 77 y luego podríamos
sumar tres decenas o treinta entonces
vamos a sumar treinta más treinta cuál
es el resultado esto es interesante si
sumas treinta a 370 obtendrás
cuatrocientos y luego tenemos otros
siete así que obtenemos 407 el resultado
es 407 y una vez más diremos que este es
sólo una forma de abordar esto por
último pero no menos importante
podríamos sumar el 4 así que estamos
aquí y sumamos 4
74 es 11 de modo que 400 74 es igual a
411 entonces cuántos kilogramos de papel
y aluminio reciclo a na
el resultado es 411 kilogramos
hemos terminado